okay so my question is going to be maybe
a bit more serious than than your
previous questions okay
but the pandemic really um it was a
really tough time i'm sure for all of us
and even before the pandemic i had i had
a really big struggle with my
self-esteem with my confidence with my
anxiety and just planned the pandemic
made it even worse like now it's really
hard for me to cope in open areas and
with people and in really crowded places
especially here in cairo every place is
really crowded and i know you've
discussed that you've had this issue for
a really long time
so i really want to know how did you
help yourself or do you have any tips
for me that i could well well the first
thing i would say uh and this is a good
really good question and it doesn't have
to be a funny question and i'm glad you
asked uh which is
you don't
the i think one of the key elements to
me for mental health is to know how many
people there are out there are thinking
and feeling the exact way you are so
there's a tendency i sometimes i think
for you to think everyone else
especially you're in this big you know
famously packed city like cairo
and you think no one else is having
these anxieties and what's wrong with me
when the truth is many many many people
are having the same issues as you so
that's the whenever i think about that i
feel better i realize uh that a lot of
us have similar wiring and you're right
uh
um i think this pandemic did isolate us
and did make us self-conscious
about
crowds it made us self-conscious about
uh our mortality it made us
self-conscious about a lot of things and
these things it it's right and normal
that that would be heightened that the
anxieties you had before the pandemic
would be heightened during you know i
think that's just very normal i am not
clearly a mental health professional
[Laughter]
but i've had a lot of help
a lot of therapy and i've investigated a
lot of different methods for looking
after my mental health and i'm a big
believer in the first thing that you
just did right now is talk about it is
be open about it
talk to people about it and you'll find
out that many people are feeling the
same way as you you know and i think the
other thing is
to like yourself because
i've talked to you for about 15 minutes
and you're just a lovely person you're
really funny you're you're smart you're
accomplished you're a terrific human
being and so you should thank you you
should just be nice to yourself be nice
to yourself and know that when you're
feeling this way do whatever you can to
a talk about it with other people that
you trust
get whatever help you think you can get
and then uh second of all just be nice
to yourself does that make sense yes yes
it is and that's really helpful
thank you yeah i'm glad you asked me
that question because i i do think
that we're all in this together uh
really and
it's whatever you're feeling in cairo
you're describing exactly how people
feel in los angeles
new york
paris buenos aires anywhere else in the
world people are feeling the way you're
feeling a lot of them
and you're clearly a sensitive nice
person
and
that's a wonderful way to be but it
means that life can sometimes be a
little tougher for you so
you have to take the good with the bad
i'm glad you're out there being a good
person and
and being a funny person and mostly
being a fan
uh of mine mostly yeah i mean that is
the most important to me sign of mental
health
is that
that means i'm very stable
so stable